what to freaking do bro what to do
should I make the front out of stone
bricks a tiny little front that there is
but glass here
next one works like that that looked bad
I feel like it looks bad
take a look yeah I think it looks bad
well be okay with would class people
come back not so much of a view but at
least let some light in
and here's well I still don't know what
to do with this I like the glass like
stuff but don't know what to do with
this I want to be sure I'm just gonna
have to do our doors better like that
I think it'll be good
and we need you when you make a button
two buttons no no two of you two of you
yes all right
now we also need the doors down
door door door
button button and personally personally
okay now let's make the roof view video
actually I want this stuff my chess on
my chest inside all my valuables daven
yeah pick up the chest just hey dang it
wait wait yeah I'm sorry I'm I was on
peaceful do something apologies that
kinda hard so it's okay yeah I put just
throw everything in here that I'm not
gonna want at the moments my mentors
cluttered I kind of just do this just
throw everything in there pick up all
the rest of you I was told about one of
the comments to call gold butter and I'm
a little I'm a little weary to do that
not weary uh cautious to do that the
fact that the guy named skydoesminecraft
does that and the be kind of sealing his
thing so to the bird who said that I
probably will not call gold butter
because it just it's something it's not
something that comes natural to me and I
don't want to like step in and someone
else's like thing if you get what I'm
saying
so yeah I problem we'll be doing that be
respectful and courteous of them so
we're gonna want wood wood wood torches
torches I need to make the roof that we
get up now which I owe diamonds on there
what should I do for the roof we got a
stone bricks
okay mixed uh-oh check something
some [ __ ] slaps hey you can make some
bucks laughs mmm
turd razandrich slabs it makes no brick
stairs you can't it just merely get
forward though out of six and I was
thinking doing stearic stairs up Oh what
should I do this is some hardcore
hardcore building up in Minecraftia I'm
crafty yeah um I might take over that
stone but I
hmm 40 40
I think I'll do I have an idea what to
do I don't idea nice simple idea this
also makes it really easy if I ever want
to build up know that this is a design
that I've used a lot and just pretty
good you can check out how our house for
the looks in the morning probably change
the ground hmm bricks bed so what would
I change the ground to make a stone
break their show shove all no not
something everybody stop everybody just
calm down
I think I'll have enough sunburn to this
year ye the bump up up up Papa Papa Papa
Papa Papa did it did it did it did it
did
other skeleton I'll change that in the
morning and the bed I want a better
position right here for now
wait go just in case we got a little
batty perfect
now we're gonna want to replace you with
you and you
well it looks nice it does feel a bit
cramped but that will change that I'm
gonna have to start breaking down these
trees so yeah I'm gonna break down these
trees and then we're gonna go find all
the new [ __ ] I really have no idea
what the order in terms of like ability
each or is so that's gonna be it's gonna
be fun to figure out yeah once all I
break all these and leaves disappear
we'll be able to get a look than what my
house looks like like if it's good or
crappy or what and this will give me a
lot of wood in the process since I
decided not to burn it down because I'm
a smart guy he should probably break
these up and like 15-minute thing is I'd
be cool you guys seem to love this
series so like every video was gotten
over 100 views except for the most
recent one but I put that up like 17
hours ago so it's sensible that doesn't
have 100 views in 17 hours how do these
trees even spawn I'm not even hitting it
oh yeah I'm some deep water we're gonna
want a way out of it and what break you
break your water goes a little slower
than above water
oh one more piece dang it stupid a water
I think my house looking a little bit
funky with this stone brick wood plank
log pieces just a little bit what I keep
hearing skeleton skillet or I'll kill
you yeah that's it yep pretty boo which
is breaking down some trees so yeah it's
spring break or it's my spring break so
happy spring break and say that
Kerber spring break what are you people
gonna be doing over break I'm probably
gonna be hanging with my buds hopefully
you guys can't hear that fan if you can
then hopefully it's not too loud if it
is then just skip to a part where
there's no fans and I just guess it got
a little bit of hot I hope you guys
enjoy well just from getting started so
it's actually a lot of colleges spring
break already ended so sucks for you pay
polish but my college no not my couch my
mush Spring Breaks going going ham so
I'm probably just gonna be chilling with
friends and like eating pizza and
watching movies and playing video games
and running cuz I'm gonna track team
yeah hope you guys all have a amazed
spring break just go hang out with
friends a lot it's always fun to do now
I just need all of these stupid leaves
disappear then we'll be good public of
all these happenings yeah this is like
it's looking a little weird you guys
don't like it I think it looks kind of
cool you guys don't like I'll change it
so many sevens
the glass is looking a weird and try
something um um it's not like more
normal feel I got almost looks weirder
okay try something with these well I got
a lot of would you try doing like honey
max bum bum like no want this like that
it sounded cool
hey don't really like it so now I'm just
gonna keep a glass since that looks the
most normal out of all of them so I give
me suggestions of what I should do with
the house to make it look not crappy
good plan sure change this to uh oh no
my dumb pig Amy you change that to would
look better
obviously I'll get the last block but
actually the last block looks well a
little bit stone brick and the inside is
also a brick okay well we don't need all
of this wood and these saplings where
you can replant it another time is the
trees are disappearing nice we get so
many settings and still break more these
trees though
I think a stack this happens I remember
I saw one one video
this guy's like your supper didn't he he
had a really funny accident which made
the video even better he's like yeah
something's something's are worth of the
so I just I just used in to smell things
so he just had saplings as his fuel and
his furnace and I was like what day
difficult
yeah I was like why would you use
saplings it wasn't theirs because he
just doesn't like replanting trees yes
no just nuts
Devlin does look a lot better with these
broken I feel like I missed a piece of
wood in here yep I still hear this
skeleton that must be a cave nearby okay
well we're going to plant you in their
plant you and the others don't be a cave
near me I don't really need you I'm you
planned these around a beachfront
property I get all these apples let's go
break this yeah broken I'm a tad bit of
lag but that's okay that's all I'm gonna
make it like some some beach thingy
don't worry one more
to get some lag due to do 30 frames
which is not too good but it's good so
one guy who's getting like 15 frames
interview I'm like I wouldn't even have
the patience to make a video like that
whoa I guess I'm a little spoiled in my
frame ok I'm going with it I don't think
that many woods I'm going to make some
more tools I'm gonna add another shovel
okay
and I'm gonna pick you up I don't think
there's more six here I wish you want an
adventure we have wood we have supply I
said I'm gonna torch that having more
torches yeah so I hear people directly
under me I'm gonna make it mine I'm
gonna make my mind rights rights right
here
you're right here's a good place